actually JD had Thanksgiving dinner at
the vegetarian restaurant well that
sounds like but like what a change in JD
this is follow that girl anywhere oh my
god that wife has whipped him into shape
it's not whipping into shape he's like
your dog how'd you like that vegetarian
food I'm a big thing you have a great
they do great seitan it was okay a sage
am hooked it's Satan what does seitan
know it's a wheat product it's like a
mushroom or whatever note Robin goes
it's a wheat product that's the furthest
thing from a mushroom so that's what I
thought
you liked it though yes I was shocked
they don't have like the that's that new
veggie burger and none of these places
have it so good I've been to a
vegetarian restaurant that had it I
believe like you branched out there well
I mean I had I got like Turkey and stuff
during the day for me Oh JD and his wife
watched the Thanksgiving Day Parade
balloons get blown up did you know that
oh they went to the park and did that
romantic thing well I don't know why
they wouldn't Twilight neither of us
thought the parade thought the parade
would be too long and stuff to go
through so we thought we'd check out the
balloons are getting blown out I can't
understand that I need us thought the
parade would be too long to go to
that's what Rose you know you know what
I meant I'll have to say tan and I can
pound it c-can I carefully he ordered
state and a shame camper Carter doesn't
even know it like I got wheat balls and
spaghetti because I know what that is I
think I've had tempeh Antron Arizona I
had a it's a mushroom did you have it
tempeh tempeh and the zucchini earns a
lot of or shy or of there
John Kimbrough and friend John Paul Wow
oh whatever you know what I mean how
thing y'all